Thank you, brother. Thank you.
You know we are nice people. He just
assaulted my wife.
Prove Jesus is a Muslim, we'll give you
$2,200 for the masjid.
Go preach it to the Zionists. Can you
prove that Jesus is a Muslim?
>> [music]
[music]
>> You confirm it. I'll be honest with you.
We do Yeah, we believe in those.
But the original version.
>> I see.
So yeah.
So no no, that's good. So like so like
our our thing is that um like obviously
like none none of our laws revelation
can be corrupted. Like he protects his
books. He protects his revelation, you
know? And so like as far as us
Christians, this is one of the most
important things about the Quran is that
it's it says that it's in line with what
came before, you know what I'm saying?
And so if it's in line with what came
before, it it doesn't make sense for
some Muslims to say that the scriptures
been corrupted, you know?
Yeah yeah yeah, we like we like
discussion, open discussion.
Yeah. So so you know you know what I'm
saying? So if the if the if Allah
confirms the scriptures with the Quran,
then they can't be corrupted, you know?
What what are your thoughts on that? I
think
there is there there is
I think there is a correct version. Mhm.
Now, I'm
not the law. I'm not God or I'm not
Allah to decide which version is correct
and which isn't. I don't think any human
being is. Would you would you say that
the one we have now is would is
different from the the scriptures the
Quran was saying are true back then?
Yeah, cuz there's contradictions amongst
if I go pull up like
a Bible from today and go back a hundred
not even a hundred years, go back sixty
years to a Baptist version of that.
There's contradictions in Psalm right
away. No, there's no, there's not. Like
there's there's not a different there's
not a baptism.
No, so the
So so you would So you would be saying
and then would you be saying that the
Baptist version of the Bible is the
correct one? Would you Is that what you
would say?
>> know which one is. Like I told you
before, I'm not God so I can't judge. So
So this Yeah. Since there's so many
different If I tell you
yo, this is the original iPhone, right?
I said this is the only one. Yeah. And
you go back in the history and you see
it has not changed in 1,400 years. This
thing has remained how I described it.
Uh-huh. But then I go to look at
something that I say a Samsung, right?
Now there is Samsung 21, 21 Plus, 21 2,
the the
the UK version of it, this version of
it, that version of it.
>> Mhm.
Then that gets kind of mis- Like I want
the original. Where do I go for the
original? Yeah, so that's That's what
I'm
>> source of the original?
>> That's what I'm saying. So if you're If
you're saying that there's a change, if
you're saying that there's like a some
type of corruption or tampering I
wouldn't I wouldn't call it corruption
or I'd say there is some change by
humans. Right. So if there's some If If
there will be change by humans, then
this would like So this would be the
problem. So the The Quran The Quran says
that The Quran says that the The
scriptures are true.
I We're We're trying to get
conversations, brother. We're We're
Yeah, more people will come. Yeah.
When they does When they When they does
that that So the media cover it. A lot
of people they don't hear about Islam.
They hear They learn
Yeah, we want We want to We want to
teach every teach everybody. We want to
teach everybody. Yeah.
Yeah.
Of course, brother. Of course.
Yeah, one of the brothers invited us
Well, we're going to schedule a a
meeting pretty soon.
But yeah.
Yeah, so that's That's why we discuss
Question for you. Why should we believe
in Allah?
Why Jesus when he's from We shouldn't.
We shouldn't. We shouldn't believe in a
brown white Jesus. That'd be wrong.
What's up, brother?
Why do I keep running Hey, David. David.
Well, you said why do I keep running
away from Sheikh Abdullah? I went to
I'm just I'm just letting him know.
Ask ask your question again.
Hey, let let David listen to his
question.
What what was your question?
Okay, so he doesn't want to talk. He
said He said, "Why are you running away
from Sheikh Abdullah?"
>> [laughter]
>> Nice to meet you, brother. So, yeah, we
we we're talking about believing in
Muhammad, Quran compared to the Bible.
What do you think, brother?
Thank you, brother.
Thank you.
Yes, well, he he
he just insulted my wife, so
Yeah, he just insulted my wife.
If I get cooked every day, cook me now.
Cook me now.
Cook me now. Cook me now, brother.
Prove Jesus is a Muslim, man, we
We'll we'll offer 2,200 to the masjid if
you prove Jesus is a Muslim.
Prove Jesus is a Muslim, we'll give you
$2,200 for the masjid.
No, we we we want the we want the we
want the good conversation.
We want the good conversation.
So, instead of telling us why
Did Muhammad do it?
Do you think Muhammad did that?
Did Muhammad do that?
Does Does anybody want to prove Jesus is
a Muslim?
Anybody want to talk?
Okay, thank you, brother. I I I want to
have a peaceful I want to have a
peaceful conversation, you know.
Same thing?
Hey.
So so
Right right right
Of course that's what I'm here for that
Can you prove to us that Jesus is a
Muslim? Hold on hold on.
Can you prove that Jesus is a Muslim
brother?
Can you prove that Jesus is a Muslim?
We are preaching the right path. Islam
is not the right path brother. That's
why we're here.
If you if you want we're able to have a
conversation.
If any brothers are welcome to have a
conversation you guys want to have a
conversation?
He's telling you to listen. Listen to
him.
Listen to him.
Good.
Say calling us clowns insulting our
wives all of this stuff. Show us to be
clowns bro. Prove it.
Prove that we're clowns by showing that
our arguments don't last that our
arguments can't stand.
If our arguments are trash come show us.
Let's talk about the Quran and the
Bible.
Because we care about you.
We are we are look brother our religion
tells us our religion tells us to reach
the lost. Okay?
Jesus went to the lost so we're going to
the lost you know?
Oh he he said he prayed to his father.
He prayed to the father?
Right right so you don't pray like Jesus
brother.
Jesus Jesus said that God is his father.
Because you're lost.
Yes yes actually.
Yes there brother brother there was a
Muslim rally in front of a church the
other week.
Brother, let's let's have a
conversation.
He ran from me. He ran from me.
Tell him yeah, we saw the video where he
ran. He didn't come out the mosque.
You're you're braver than Sheikh Uthman.
At least you're talking to me from your
car.
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> At least you At least you're talking to
me from your car. You're braver than
Uthman. Y'all know y'all know Sheikh
Sheikh Uthman been running, bro. Let's
be for real. Yeah. Y'all know he ran.
Y'all seen it.
I agree. That's what they did. They so
they started, bro. I don't want to talk
about that. I want to talk about some
substance.
OKAY. CAN CAN I CHECK your hair?
Yeah. Good. So So let's talk. Let's
talk. Let's talk.
So what So what do you think, man? What
about Jesus being a Muslim? I think
that's a good start topic. What you
think?
Okay. So So why do you think him being a
prophet makes him a Muslim?
He had 99 prophets?
Yes. Okay. So being a prophet of God
makes him a Muslim?
What makes him a Muslim though?
Oh, nothing.
Okay.
He's He's good, brother.
So So we we just heard we just heard
that nothing made Jesus a Muslim
according to him.
Jesus had 99 prophets. I mean Allah had
99 prophets. Jesus is one of them, but
nothing makes him a Muslim. So that
doesn't make any sense to me.
Say that again.
We We We believe in the Bible, brother.
We believe in Jesus Christ.
We're Christians.
Yeah, we're Christians. We We follow
Christ.
Brother, look. Christ Christ literally
said, "Go to the cities. Go to the towns
of the lost. You're lost."
No, I'm starting with you.
You're not
>> not a believer.
I want you to become a believer,
brother.
I want you to experience the truth.
He's a safety hall monitor.
He's a hall monitor. We want you to
experience the truth, brother. That's
Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ loves you. He wants you to
have the truth. There's no truth outside
of Jesus Christ, bro.
There's no truth outside of Jesus
Christ. I'm letting you know, okay?
But, God bless you, man. God bless you.
May Christ enter your heart, man. May
God open your minds. May the spirit fill
you.
You know, Jesus loves you, brother.
I'm praying for you right now, brother.
I'm making dua right now for you.
I pray to the most high God that he
reveals himself to you in the truest
way. In the truest way possible.
Alhamdulillah ya Rasul
Look at the hall monitor. He keep
keeping up. Y'all go go go. Clear the
way. Get all Get out of here.
Look look look. We got to get him a hall
Get Get Get them Get Get them leave them
him telling people to leave. Get them
all. Y'all know that he's telling them
to leave. Telling Getting them scared of
conversation.
What What better place to reach a Muslim
than at the masjid? See the police? They
brought the color police. Police pulled
up over there. That's good. We ain't
trespassing or nothing.
They always do it. Stop it.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Let's hear him. Let's
some questions like that, you know? What
did you say? We believe in nothing
before we believe in That's a simple
question like Why should we believe
Muhammad to be We're supposed to believe
in Muhammad and when we ask why None of
them is How dare you? We can't
Muslims ask us all the time, "Why you
believe in Jesus?"
I said you believe in Jesus. They choose
They go to churches and stand in front
Go Go to a YouTube channel called David
Wood. They had Muslims standing out in
front of his church and he had to come
He's a pastor. He came out and had to
talk to the Muslims and he didn't He
didn't kick them out or get mad. He had
a discussion with them. What What was he
doing at the church? Like what was the
reason They were trying to preach Islam.
They You to see why he was Christian.
Everybody does it, bro. It's It's It's
just cuz you don't see it doesn't mean
it's not happening, but it's on YouTube.
They do it all the time. Well, I've
never seen it. And if they're doing that
Well, if you've never seen it, don't say
it doesn't happen, you know? I've never
said it. What I'm saying is
we would not do that. And it's like
everybody have the freedom to believe
whatever they want to believe.
>> He just He just gave you an example
where Muslims do that, bro.
>> me to show the video? I want to see it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I want to see it cuz I
Everybody should believe whatever they
want to believe in, you
But don't you don't you think they
should believe the truth? What? Don't
you believe they should believe the
truth?
We believe in Jesus. We just believe he
was a prophet. But you See, that's the
That's the point. If you If you say
That's like That's like this, brother.
If I say I believe in If I If I say Just
really quick. If I say I believe in
Muhammad, right? If I say I believe in
Muhammad, but I don't believe that he's
a prophet, do I really believe in
Muhammad?
Right. So, I can't So, I can't say that
I believe in someone if I deny who they
are, right?
>> So, quick question
>> So, that's the thing, bro. Hold on. Just
Let me I'm going to I'm going to let you
ask your question. I'm just saying I'm
just saying with Jesus, you say he's a
prophet. How you doing, brother? You You
don't You don't really believe in Jesus.
Quick question for you. Yeah.
God bless you, bro.
invited him inside of his church and
then talked to him inside the church,
too.
So, they The Muslims do it, bro. Quick
question for you. Yeah. Do you believe
Jesus is God?
>> Of course.
So
And that's why I say you don't believe
in Jesus.
>> Show me where Jesus ever claimed to be
God
Sure.
Yeah, I got you. I got you, brother.
You You
>> Jesus never claimed to be God. Yes, he
did.
He can't be God, the son of God, and the
God. That's like saying he can't be
Messiah, he can't be a prophet, and he
can't be a messenger. These are all the
Can Can Jesus Can Jesus be Hold on.
Listen. Can Jesus be prophet Can Jesus
be prophet, Messiah, and messenger?
The prophet is the same as messenger.
No, it's not. Those are two different
things. One One receives a book, one is
just a warner. So, that's why the Quran
makes a distinction between prophets and
messengers.
>> of God is a prophet. Every messenger of
God is a prophet.
>> Yeah, but not every prophet of God is a
messenger.
That's the point.
No, that's what the Quran says, right?
He can't be God, the son of God. I heard
you. First time. I'm just saying, you're
saying that he can't have these
different titles for himself. Yes, he
can. He never claimed to be God. No
where in the Bible. All right. Who's the
first and the last, brother?
He can't He can't
He promised he said he's going to come
back. We know that. I know. Who's Who's
the first and the last?
All right. So, you know that in chapter
57, verse three of the Quran, it says
that Allah is the first and the last.
All right? It's one of his 99 names. The
first, that's one. The last is another.
So, he's the first and the last, which
means that he's the infinite. He's
eternal. He's God. All right? So,
um
with that being said, so
>> where in the Bible I'm about to show
you. I'm about to show you. I'm about to
show you where Jesus says the same thing
about himself. Jesus said he's God?
Yeah. He says he's the first and the
last. Look. No, no, no, no. He says, "I
am the Alpha and the Omega, the first
and the last, the beginning and the
end." So, Jesus said He never said he's
not God. He's never said he's God.
>> the first you just said the first and
the last is God.
What what it So, who's the first and the
last? I ask you again. Who's the first
and the last in the Quran?
What's the meaning of first and the
last? I'll let me show you, brother. So,
look.
I'll show you.
You still didn't show me where does it
say he's God. Okay. He's never claimed
to be God. He never asked people to
worship him. I'm going to show you this
right quick. Jesus was here to get
people closer to God. You You believe in
the Quran, right? I believe in the
Quran. So, you you know there's no way
in the Quran you you go with what the
Quran says, right?
You do Look. Don't Don't Don't run away
now. Look. All right. Let me just show
you one last verse. Look. You guys are
confused, bro. Okay, look. Here's the
Here's the Quran verse, brother. Look.
It says, "He is the first and the last.
That's Allah, right?
No, he Okay, listen.
>> Allah is not the first and the last?
Allah is the first and the last. He
never He never said Jesus is the first
and the last.
>> Very good. So, it's So, Jesus said Jesus
said I'm the first and the last. Just
because he said it doesn't make him God.
>> Okay, but at least but but at least he's
claiming to be God, right? Jesus never
claimed to be God.
>> If he says I'm the first and the last,
that's a claim to be God, right?
>> he be God.
>> All right, so when he says when Allah
says he's the first and the last, that's
not a claim to be God? Listen and
listen, he never says he want to be
worship. He's the equal
>> But you're not No, he did. He said honor
me the same way you honor the Father,
the same way you honor God.
>> No. How do you honor God? Through
worship, right? We worship We're
supposed to worship God. We're not
supposed to worship
>> Right. So, do you do you honor God
through your worship? Yes. Okay, so
Jesus
I know, but I know, brother, listen.
Jesus says the same way you honor God is
the same way you honor me. I don't know
what Bible you're reading.
>> I'm reading the Bible. That is not a
real Bible. Then show me the real Bible.
That is not a real Bible. Show me the
real Bible, man.
Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Hey, we'll Hey, you'll be We'll be back
tomorrow. So, come tomorrow.
All right. Take care, man. God bless
you, bro. Be safe.
It's God.
It's God. [music]